will the yellowstone dutton ranch
finally fall will the new sheriff make
it his business to shut down the duttons
these questions and more from
yellowstone season four
as the fourth season gets underway we
learn that casey survived the attack in
the previous season's finale there are
no magic solutions to this puzzle though
just casey's dogged determination and
sharpshooting skills which helped him
stay alive and kill the men who came
after him but in the aftermath of the
attack things changed for casey and his
family monica and tate were also targets
of assassination and though the pair
survived thanks to tate's handling of a
shotgun they were left traumatized
looking out for the emotional well-being
of his family first casey decides to
relocate taking his wife and son off the
yellowstone dutton ranch and buying a
house in prior montana it seems to do
wonders for young tate and monica too
and it's not long before she tells casey
that they are expecting another child
after yet another mysterious wolf
sighting though casey seeks the help of
his friends on the reservation who
convinced him to undertake a vision
quest for answers there he encounters
images of his dead brother lee
flashbacks of his time in the war and
the wolf his spirit guide in the form of
a young native american woman with what
we've seen casey and his family go
through this season and the comfort he
seemingly found off the ranch we wonder
if he'll keep his promise to his father
and return to yellowstone is this
sheridan's way of writing casey out of
the series or just a new story arc for
him
it was way back in season 2 that jaime's
ex-girlfriend christina dropped a major
bombshell on him she is pregnant with
his child jaime begged her to allow him
to be a part of the baby's life but she
announced that she couldn't be with him
if he was still working with the duttons
before leaving him again christina gave
jaime a fateful choice
serve your father's family or serve your
own
like it or not that choice is coming
it wouldn't be an immediate decision for
him as jaime does return to serve his
father as a weapon of the ranch against
his enemies but then he discovers he's
not really a dutton at all having been
adopted as a baby and it's when he
reconnects with his birth father garrett
randall in season four that christina
resurfaces with their baby in tow but
after season four's conclusion there is
still no indication that anyone else in
the dutton family knows of the existence
of jamie's child and it's anyone's guess
how they'll react when they find out
could beth be looking for blood
vengefully resentful that she can't have
children of her own could john see this
child as a possible heir to the
yellowstone as he has made it clear he
still views jaime as his son we'll have
to wait and see
speaking of jaime one major plot line
that is still left hanging at the end of
season 4 is the fate of the governor's
race the adopted dutton split away from
his family to pursue the office against
the wishes of his father and in defiance
of jon entering his own name in the race
a potential political rivalry between
father and son figures could be a
fascinating story for yellowstone but
jaime still hasn't officially filed his
own candidacy leaving the plot up in the
air for now there were a few wrinkles
before the fourth season finale namely
the existence of jaime's birth father
garrett randall with the family now
aware of the role jaime's birth father
played in the attempt on their lives
there's a whole new can of worms opened
even if garrett himself doesn't survive
the fourth season but jaime insists he
had a plan for how to deal with jon's
knowledge of his father so we're curious
what that could mean as it stands the
race to be montana's next governor is
just heating up and could be the main
story of the fifth season
in the season opener beth meets carter
while outside the hospital that her
father is recovering in and the pair
bond over their mutual family problems
carter's father is dying and when he
needs someone by his side to say goodbye
beth uncharacteristically offers to be
support for him
are you a friend of the family
i guess i am now
after a little tough love from beth and
rip carter winds up working at
yellowstone as a ranch hand and living
with beth and rip in a quasi family unit
since we learned in season three that
beth is unable to be a mother we've
pondered what that might mean for her
future on the ranch unable to be a part
of her family's continuing legacy but
since the introduction of the young
carter it has increasingly felt like she
might just have a crack at parented yet
from carter's introduction it seemed
that he might be the next rip wheeler a
troubled angry orphaned boy brought to
the ranch through a compassionate dutton
and raised to be a cowboy but in the
finale beth makes it clear she wants no
part of being a mother though it's hard
to deny that's exactly what's happening
still the question remains what will
carter become will he be the next
surrogate dutton like rip a future
wrangler and yellowstone enforcer or
with casey and his family off the ranch
perhaps for good could carter stand to
become the next generation of the dutton
family with tate out of the picture
we've seen jon getting closer to carter
in the same way he was bonding with tate
earlier in the series so there's no
telling which way this one could go
for four long years on yellowstone we've
watched beth dutton's hatred for her
brother jamie percolate a few times
boiling over into overt aggression in
the fourth season's final episode the
feud between the siblings reached what
may be its climax with beth discovering
that it was jaime's birth father garrett
randall who ordered the assassination
attempts on the duttons beth gives jaime
two choices neither of which are good
before jaime chooses a third option at
the end of the episode we see jaime
murder randall openly weeping for what
he had to do to save his future just
when he thought he was in the clear beth
appears while jaime dumps the body into
the canyon you should have picked
options one or two
three's gonna be worse
it's your mind now
but does this threat really carry the
weight she seems to think it does her
own husband rip wheeler has buried more
than one murder at the bottom of the
same cliff and revealing jaime's
involvement with randall could threaten
to expose more than one family secret
including rip's part in the cover-up of
a reporter jaime killed could this
threat come back to haunt her next
season and moreover will the death of
garrett randall have greater
consequences that we don't yet see there
are still many questions surrounding
randall that need answering including
what he's been up to behind jaime's back
he seemed to be expecting his death just
before it came so it may also be
possible he had a posthumous backup plan
ready having promised to go after the
duttons again
a divisive new foil for the dutton
family summer higgins is an
environmental activist added to the cast
this season summer comes to town under
the auspices of ending animal cruelty
and saving montana's rich untamed lands
from the change that industrialists are
attempting to bring to the region along
the way she becomes a pawn of beth
dutton's desire to sabotage market
equity's land deal and winds up facing
life in prison because of beth's vicious
machinations thankfully jon feels it
isn't right for beth to do what she did
and attempts to sway the judge to let
summer off the hook it's the right thing
to do
right barely factors into it anymore
john
it's touch and go but in the end summer
gets a much reduced sentence and it's
said that she'll likely be freed from
her jail cell within a year while this
may seem like the end of her story on
yellowstone we can't help but wonder if
there's more of a role for her to play
she's still a potentially powerful ally
as leader of an environmentalist
movement and she and jon seem to share
some of the same goals if she's only
expected to do eight months behind bars
we may not have seen the last of her
at the beginning of the season jimmy
finds himself seriously injured not by
the attack on the ranch but by a
misguided attempt to rodeo again
breaking his promise to john dutton but
he's still a member of the family and
jon isn't ready to give up on jimmy all
together so he orders the young wannabe
cowboy off to texas to a notorious ranch
called the four sixes a place that works
their men harder than any other if the
four sixes can't turn jimmy into a
cowboy nobody can jimmy does indeed
learn to cowboy and even meets emily who
becomes his fiancee in a rapid fire
romance when jimmy returns to
yellowstone he promises to stay until
his debt to the ranch is repaid but jon
graciously lets him leave with emily and
start a new life at the four sixes
what's next for him we likely won't get
answers in the next season of
yellowstone and will instead see jimmy's
story continue in the new spin-off
series four sixes
in one of the season's many shocking
moments john and rip meet sheriff
haskell at a roadside diner only to
discover the restaurant is in the middle
of being held up by a group of lowlifes
rip and john are able to turn the tables
but not before the thugs fatally wound
haskell in the penultimate episode of
the season we meet haskell's replacement
commander ramsey john is clearly rattled
when ramsay is announced as haskell's
interim replacement and it suggested
that jon is unsure if ramsay can be
trusted not because he's corrupt but
because he might not be
though things will be different with me
in charge no rules huh
still the old rules
but now they'll be enforced
we only get a brief look at ramsay in
his new role as sheriff but he's already
made it clear he's going to do things
differently ramsay seems acutely aware
of haskell's corruption setting him up
to be a major thorn in the dutton's side
as the series moves into its fifth
season but the question remains will
sheriff ramsey be a momentary roadblock
or will he stick around to cause trouble
we're not suggesting for a moment that
season 5 of yellowstone will be the last
but we could be entering a new stage of
the series and wonder if we might be
seeing the last days of the yellowstone
dutton ranch surrounded by enemies on
all sides there seems to be no way out
for john and his family who have all but
acknowledged their days could be
numbered with one of the country's
biggest firms at their back in market
equities whose principal owner now has a
personal reason to go after their land
after beth crossed her and allies
dropping left and right it feels like
the noose is finally closing around the
duttons could the series fifth year see
them lose their ranch and fight to get
it back it might seem like a far-fetched
notion for a series that's built around
a family willing to die before they lose
their land but where yellowstone is
concerned there seem to be no limits to
the stories that lay ahead check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]